got a lot of sports fans here I'm sure
the NBA playoffs are in full swing the
games have been terrific and there are a
ton of young stars who are starting to
shine as a big hoops fan I couldn't be
more excited Andy aren't you excited
not really Connor and I'm not into
sports come on Andy don't you know
anything about sports not at all going
not even the most basic details nope
then you know what time it is I sure do
that's right it's time for Andy Richter
sports blast
[Applause]
all right
welcome mr. Lords welcome to sports
plays let's buy some sports sports
tonight we've got a ton of NBA playoff
action to talk about first of all NBA
stands for not Baseball Association
sports because it's not baseball it's
basketball that means it's time to head
over the wall basketball wall of
basketballs sports according to
Wikipedia basketball is a limited
contact sport slid on a rectangular
court and the object is to shoot a
basketball through the hoop Wow
and now here's sports blast
correspondent : O'Brien wish the
basketball scores thanks Andy
here tonight's basketball scores 128
4108 119 247 for 95 for 82 41:34 106 for
111 sports 87
thanks time let's wrap it up with our
sports clip of the week sports quit of
the week Wow
great clip car great clip back to you
Conan thanks Andy
back to you back to you Conan thanks
Andy back to you oh that's a good one
back to you Conan back to you Andy
thanks Colin back to you back to you
Andy
but you : back to you Andy got you :
back to you Andy well that's it for our
show for tune in next season for another
episode Andy Richter sport blasts
you
you